when creating data proc clusters for
using open source big data tools such as
spark hadoop or presto it is imperative
that they are configured with
well-defined security settings to
prohibit unauthorized use and access to
the cluster google cloud contains
several options for how to control the
security settings on your cluster so
let's jump in and learn more about this
[Music]
in this video we'll be going over how to
secure your dataproc clusters using a
custom virtual private cloud or vpc
a vpc is a managed networking service
for your google cloud resources
resources within your vpc are secured
via isolation from the public internet
for more info on virtual private cloud
check out the video linked in the
description
we'll start by setting up the cluster to
allow the cluster nodes to connect to
one another the cluster cannot
distribute workloads to its nodes
without this
additionally we'll also allow ssh access
into the cluster
ssh is important for submitting
workloads with tools such as spark
submit and for making modifications to
long-running clusters we can do this by
creating a custom vpc with two firewall
rules one that allows the nodes of the
cluster to interact with each other and
another that enables ssh access into the
dataproc cluster these rules will
provide the dataproc cluster with basic
security features
next we'll create the cluster with our
custom vpc we'll then test the
functionality of the vpc by submitting a
spark job to the cluster using the cloud
sdk
as well as show how to ssh into the
cluster we'll then delete the individual
firewall rules and show how we've
protected the cluster and the job
successfully without the firewall rules
we are locked out and the cluster is
effectively rendered unusable yay
you can jump ahead to any of these steps
by visiting the chapters in the youtube
description below
start by searching for vpc network in
the search bar and click on it
next click create vpc network
provide a name for the vpc network
next we'll create a subnet using the
custom subnet creation mode
provide a name for your new subnet
select a region in this case we'll pick
uscentral1 provide an ip address we'll
go with 10.0.0.0
forward slash 9.
leave the rest of the defaults as is and
press create
this should take about 20 seconds or so
to finish creating
[Music]
when it's finished creating click on it
click on firewall rules
then click add firewall rule
we'll first create a firewall rule that
will allow nodes of the cluster to
communicate with each other provide a
name for the rule
make sure the name of your network is
selected
make sure the direction of traffic is
set to ingress
for target tags provide the name
dataproc
network
for sourceip ranges input 10.0.0.0
forward slash 9.
for protocols and ports check the box
next to tcp
and enter the ports 0-65535
to allow access on all ports
also check the box next to udp and input
all
press create
you'll see the new firewall rule here
now let's create our second firewall
rule by again clicking add firewall rule
this firewall rule will allow ssh access
to the cluster
provide a name for the rule
make sure the name of your network is
selected
for target tags again provide the name
data proc dash network
for source ip ranges input 0.0.0.0
forward slash 0.
for protocols and ports check the box
next to tcp and enter the port 22 which
is the port used for ssh login
press create
we'll now create our dataproc cluster
configured with our vpc
in the search bar type in dataproc and
click on it
next click create cluster
provide a name
select the same region as your vpc
leave everything else in this tab as is
next select customize cluster
under network configuration for the
primary network drop down select your
network and for the sub network
drop-down select your subnet under
network tags enter the same tags you
created earlier dataproc network
everything else will be left as is go
ahead and press create
we see our cluster is provisioning which
will take about 90 seconds to finish
we'll skip the video ahead here
now that our cluster is finished
provisioning let's try submitting a job
to it using the dataproc jobs api
click on the cloud shell button to open
up your cloud shell
now we'll copy this command into the
terminal to submit an example job to
spark in this case we'll use spark pi
which will approximately compute the
value of pi
great this worked we can see the success
message in the output now we'll go back
to our vpc and remove the firewall rule
again search for vpc network
click on my-vpc-network-demo
then firewall rules
check the box next to the cluster dash
comms rule then press delete
now we'll try submitting the spark job
again in our cloud shell
after about 60 seconds it will fail
we'll again skip the video ahead
[Music]
as you can see the cluster failed to
execute the job as it wasn't able to
communicate with the other nodes this
means having the rule there worked
go back to the dataproc page by typing
dataproc into the search bar
click on the cluster
then click the vm instances tab
next to the master node press ssh
we are now ssh into the cluster let's
see if removing the firewall rule for
ssh prevents us from doing this again
close this ssh window and now let's
search for vpc network again
click on my dash
vpc-network demo
and then firewall rules check the box
next to the allow ssh rule then press
delete
go back to the dataproc page by typing
dataproc into the search bar
from the clusters page click on the
cluster
click on the vm instances tab
next to the master node click ssh
this process should hang for about a
minute or so before unsuccessfully
connecting
we'll skip the video again here
this means the allow dash ssh firewall
rule worked as well
in this video we created a vpc network
with two firewall rules in place to
limit access
we then created a dataproc cluster
configured with the vpc network to
secure it via isolation from the public
internet
we then tested the functionality of the
cluster and showed this functionality
disappear as we removed the firewall
rules
you can read more about network
configuration for your dataproc cluster
in the google cloud docs please go to
this link for more information thanks
for watching
[Music]
you